[Music] Alright, I've
finished cleaning for three years.
Organizing my room means organizing my
mind. [
Music] I wonder how long it's been since I felt so refreshed. [Music]
Now then, [Music
]
Now, what you've been waiting for
[Music] A
company that's too good to be true.  The fact that I drink this much beer in the morning without going to work is
truly miraculous water or divine water.I feel
immoral drinking it on weekdays when I would normally be working.Is it a relief
from the hard work and responsibilities of work?
How can we not call this happiness?  I guess they're calling.
This is an image taken from above Tokyo.
Fires are rising from everywhere. I
still can't accept that this is a real scene. There are
dead station workers who can even go to this studio, and they're
rushing in right there.
Internet and phone calls are everywhere.  The lines are broken, and there's
been no announcement from government agencies. I wonder if
this country is even functioning anymore.
[Music]
But then again, the world is in big trouble.
What's next?
But today I'm all about beer.